and we're scoreless headed to the second
two down for jorge alfaro runner at
second
it's that one hard and past the dive of
reilly into left field duvall cuts it
off but cooper's coming around third and
the marlins have a one-nothing lead and
now jazz chisholm out of the nine hole
tonight
and jazz chisholm with a drive out to
right center field and that's going to
go off the base of the wall here comes
alfaro around third chisholm heading two
third with an rbi triple didn't miss his
first home run by that much
but it's two nothing miami well a great
swing by jazz
one of the best balls he's hit in his
young career what a way for ozzy albies
to make his return his first at-bat will
come with the bases loaded and nobody
out in the second inning here it is
little roller cooper is gonna charge and
flip to the pitcher covering all bees
will pick up at rbi as swanson scores he
puts it in play
the other runners move up 90 feet so
productive out the braves are on the
board
ender with a hit would get into double
digits in rbis
fly ball towards center marte drifts
back that'll be plenty deep enough to
get the game tied tagging moving to
third and close play and not in time
oh that was close
adam duvall called safe on a bang bang
play ender in ciarte on the first pitch
delivers a sacrifice fly and we're tied
at two the marlins are going to check
and did duvall slide on top of the foot
oh looks like he got to the bag the only
question is did the tag beat him so if
this call has changed not only will it
be the
third out of the inning at third base
but the run won't score and the marlins
would maintain the lead so the verdict
is in and he is safe all right thank you
very much first and third two out
freddie popped up his first time up
freddy jumps on the first one drives it
to right and a diving try can't be made
harrison couldn't make the play
duval scores acuna on his way to third
he'll stand there safely and atlanta's
taking the lead
hit number 14.99 for freeman earns him
his 33rd rbi so now it's 3-2 first and
third and marcelo
little pop
shallow left long run brenson he's not
going to get there that drops in and the
braves are first and third the marlins
to death ozuna with the bloop single
earns him an rbi and the braves extend
the lead
darno the ninth man to hit in the inning
high fly ball to left brinson going back
to the track to the wall he cannot get
it
a free run homer by darno
freeman ambushed him darno ambushed him
and the braves have a gigantic inning
seven runs are in still two out bring
riley to the plate swanson now hitting
304
live drive left field another hit dance
be a late break they're gonna wave him
around here he comes throw headed to the
plate too high
and it's an 8-2 atlanta lead and adam
duvall is the bat
fly ball toward right center harrison on
the run still going that ball is in the
ballpark what an inning for atlanta
they are destroying the marlins first
pitches
and the braves have scored 10 and
they're not done yet
as the albies picked up an rbi much
earlier in the inning
fly ball left center marte on his horse
he's going to turn that one's going to
sail out of here welcome back ozzy albe
an 11 run inning 10 of these 11 runs
have come after that fateful review call
to third base think about that
two on for lewis brinson
and brinson with a fly ball out to deep
left field and it is gone a three-run
home run for louis brinson his second of
the year and the marlins get a little
bit closer so they're off and running
here in the third inning maybe they get
13. as this ball is launched deep right
center field did he get enough he did a
line drive home run bombs away in
atlanta ga what a way to pick up number
1500 major league hits
5 atlanta
with his first major league extra base
hit and rbi triple in the second and
just missed a home run
and jazz chisholm who puts a charge into
this one right center goodbye home run
first of his career
almost got one his last time hits it a
little bit further this time
congratulations jazz
three balls two strikes one out here it
comes to aguilar and he sends one in the
air to right field and acuna will play
this one off the wall
and rounding third is rojas aguilar into
second and
safe at third
is starling martay so now 13 to 7. it's
now 13-8 atlanta now the marlins have to
face freddie with the bases loaded and
freddie smokes it to second at full jazz
chisholm he was screened by acuna the
ball into shallow right center acuna
runs through the red light the throne
goes to the marlins on deck circle and
atlanta gets three runs out of that it's
16 to eight atlantic two on one out
walls average up to 262
and he hits one high in the air toward
left look at that ball carry toward the
fence at the fence leaping try it is
gone
adam duvall with another home run a two
homer five rbi four run game for adam
duvall and now they got 19 runs first
and third still one out cora cunha and
acuna launches that ball left center on
the first pitch no doubt about it to
centerfield a record-setting night in
atlanta braves history with 22 runs the
braves have now hit six homers in this
game and we're only in the fifth two out
bases loaded acuna
and acuna shoots it to right that ball
is well hit al farah going back it's
over his head it's off the wall two runs
score
ncrt will stop at third the ball gets
away and now ender comes home to score
and the braves have a new franchise
record and runs it's 25 to eight and the
braves have the bases loaded again and
who's coming up to do more damage adam
duvall fly ball hammer deep left it's a
grand slam for adam duvall i can't
believe it and the braves have scored 29
times the atlanta braves are one of four
teams in baseball history to score 29
runs in a game